One of our next guests is one
of the biggest social media stars on the planet.
She rose to fame in 2019 on TikTok
and now has more than 85 million followers.
That's just crazy.
(audience applauds loudly)
It's just.
I mean, I was really excited to have a conversation with her
because she has the ear and eyes of so many people.
So this is our conversation with Addison Rae.
Take a look.
(audience applauds loudly)
Hi.
Like where did you get the confidence
to put yourself out there
and have that wink and a smile?
I guess growing up, my mom
and my family have always been
just really uplifting and kind,
and always like wanting me to express myself
in all the ways I could.
And I grew up in dancing, which I always loved,
'cause I like, and if you danced ever or cheered,
it's like, oh, facial.
And we like to say A, E, I, O, U
and I'm like, all right, I've kept that forever now
'cause I always do facial expressions.
Like just to kind of give it like that extra emotion,
especially in photos and stuff.
So, thank you.
But just like confidence-wise, yeah.
Like always being influenced by people around me
that were just really positive
and like always brought out the best in me, I guess.
I mean, okay, so you have 85 million followers.
Do you go with authenticity and mood,
today is a dance day?
Do you sometimes you wake up and go,
okay, today's more introspective?
I have things to think about
and learn and explore with everybody.
How do you gauge it?
I honestly just kind of follow my gut.
I think there are days when I'm like,
all right, today's a dance day.
Like I'm gonna learn a dance
and I'm gonna make it good.
And then my mom also too will be like,
all right, let's do a dance today.
So like the other day, I was teaching her a dance.
And the other days, I'm like, okay,
how can I like learn more and understand more
about other people in the world around me.
But I mean, it really just depends.
I kinda follow my gut and just do
whatever makes me feel good,
which is kind of been my thing this year.
I'm like, all right, what can make you feel the best
and also make people feel the best around you too?
Okay, well, you're a beauty maven.
I heard you have three tips.
And literally, ever since I heard that,
been like, what are the three tips,
tell me now, teach me.
(Addison laughs lightly)
Okay, so for me, I'd probably say,
like one big one that I always do,
is I love matching my lipstick to my blush.
So I'll like use my lipstick as blush.
Yes!
Which like, yes,
okay, thank God I'm not the only one,
'cause some people look at me
like I'm crazy when I do that.
But I'll use my lipstick as a blush.
That's number one for me, I've always done that.
I think it's just so good to also have a monochromatic look.
So I'll use even my lipstick on my eyes sometimes,
like just in the crease.
I don't know, weird, but I think it looks cute.
And then, I love using an eyebrow pencil as freckles,
'cause it of like gives that like faded-ish.
But also like ties together the look in a way, which I love.
And then, I found this facial steamer
that I actually like live and breath the by.
And it's almost like being in a steam room,
but it's just like a portable facial steamer.
And I like use it all the time
and I just like sit in front of it with the mask on
and then just breathe in like this humidity.
And I'm from the south, so i love humidity,
love the misty feeling.
And it cleans my face out so good.
And that's like one thing that I'm like,
everyone should definitely have
a facial steamer in their life,
'cause if you don't know a facial steamer,
meet her immediately.
(audience applauds loudly)
Okay, now I'm so excited about your new fragrance line,
the AF collection by Addison Rae.
And you have 3 scents, let's call them vibes,
of chill, happy and hyped.
Mm-hmm, they're super fun bottles that change colors.
So they're like work with your mood.
And there's a science-backed process
that we went through to really make these scents
trigger different feelings you have.
So like chill can make you more relaxed.
Happy can make you, just in a better mood.
And then, hyped is like energy.
And they also change colors with heat and they like,
I'll try to rub my hands together,
but this one (exclaims) is yellow.
Once it, there we go.
Oh my gosh!
This one's yellow.
I know, so once you get it super warm, they change colors.
So it's like a mood ring, which is super fun
and reminiscent of when I was born, which is 2000.
So like early 2000s, mood rings,
things like that and they change color.
So it's really fun.
An interactive experience.
See, this one turns blue.
Yeah.
I love that.
Be sure to check out Addison's new frequency line
on AddisonRaeFragrance.com.
(audience applauds loudly)
Thank you, Addison!
And by the way, Addison and I
are gonna do some fun stuff on social.
She is posing a really fun question to me.
So check out the DrewBarrymoreShow.com
and our YouTube channel and all of our digital platforms
because me and Addison Rae are gonna play.